you both are filmmakers turned actors do
you consider yourself actors do you
consider yourself filmmakers what is
your label or no labels I don't know I'm
a really good actor so I consider myself
an act or mac torrent or thespian yeah
yeah thespian sir JD sir thanks unlike
this out I like the sound of that um I
hope that came off as a joke but it did
it did but everybody hates you it's okay
no we love you Venice please don't hate
we love you uh yeah uh I started out
doing acting I went to acting school but
but I currently did that because my is
this weird my dad didn't really have the
confidence that be able to could have
film school sorry dad we're okay now
though um but like literally yeah he was
like maybe acting school cuz i think i
was interested in both you know but in
high school I made short films and stuff
for instead of it for an english project
instead of like writing something i did
a short film thing so yeah but uh but
anyway by like I think of myself should
we back up oh yeah I'll back up where's
the Manson i was born on a on an old
motorcycles clear all right they are ya
okay I think of myself as an actor and
director okay I was a shorter it's no so
much yeah what about you J um well this
I've only recently started acting and um
only recently started thinking myself as
an actor it's weird to say I don't know
why but I do now I would say I'm an
actor but yeah I prior to recently I
mean I've been the main camera operator
on everything that my brother and I have
done and it's never been really even
possible physically for me to do be in
anything so I've seen you direct a
little bit and you know you you know
you're you're you're emotionally
involved as much as that the actors yeah
yeah you know
so I don't feel like that's I was
thinking on the way over here today
that's probably why it wasn't as much of
some jump or it's not like oh all of a
sudden why are you acting right right
you're just as involved and like you
would because you guys improvised so
much and you know we did a bit on Manson
too it's like what about what if you say
that you know it's like you're just
you're inhabiting it yeah almost as much
yeah thanks man nice i'm loving i'm
feeling the love in the room sigh this
is awesome just kidding great um so
knowing that you have you know several
different hats if you will sorry for the
cheesy reference to that but do you
compartmentalize how you approach a
project or is it still the same in terms
of yeah as an actor or a filmmaker I
mean for me it was almost like secondary
that I was an actor on you know this
movie man's and family vacation cuz uh
it was really just my friend Jay Davis
had this very interesting idea that came
very much from his life and I thought it
was funny and I thought it was you know
had a lot of depth to it and it was a
mystery and a thriller and a road movie
was all this stuff going on was just
exciting and he wanted to make it and I
was like I want to help you make this
movie and then he said oh and I'd like
you to play you know the guy who's the
straight-laced brother and I was like
you know it kind of came his instinct on
that was that Jay Davis has had a weird
obsession with Charles Manson his whole
life and I have always been personally
deeply disturbed by that I was like yeah
I can do that on film no problem because
we've been doing it since I've known him
and also my dad it was a lawyer and I
was playing a lawyer I was like yeah it
seems makes sense and this is a good way
for me to be on set and help you make
this movie so I literally didn't even
think about it as me being an actor or
only recently it was like yes I am a
lead in a feature film that's weird but
it's it just comes from this place of
like we're going to make this thing and
that's how my brother and I have always
done it was just like two dudes in a
cave come out of the cave make something
go back in the cave and edit it so it's
just kind of like an afterthought that
I'm an actor so when you asked like are
you consider yourself an actor I'm just
like I just like make movies and stuff
and sometimes
in them now is how my brain works it
okay well then is for you you moved from
the Washington area to New York and now
to LA is that right or maybe your time
that timeline is wrong yeah I'm a
rolling stone you're rollin stone okay
great well I heard you say previously
that you're kind of scared of auditions
which I would think that would be odd
know so on your boss I excel at
auditions my agent listening I was try
that one more time good no no that's
okay oh no he says as fluid is that left
did you see that I am great at
auditioning nailed it and your name it
and see I'm scared of auditions uh what
what do you mean no I said white good
words I'm sorry okay no no well I
members know I went to acting school I
went to NYU said the experimental
theatre but you know did all kinds
acting and they're not just weird acting
and but when I got out of school I
always just what I liked about that
program at anyway was that it was about
self generating your own work there was
a lot of like one man show type classes
and you know improv classes and so you
know if you don't go on to do theatre
you you know it's like close to being a
writer and just being a like a maker of
stuff and sometimes you're in it
sometimes you're not so I never really I
never practiced auditioning I just
didn't that wasn't even my brain I don't
know why it wasn't I mean I was just
like well I'm just I'm graduated I time
to get a job and make stuff you know
right so i just made theatre and then
start making videos so what's your take
on this whole sort of la actor route
because if you were in bass ackwards
which i absolutely love and you played
yourself lynus right that was your yeah
yeah and so how is it now to be not the
sort of the creator of it but then the
one being picked I mean it's great yeah
it's theirs I feel more like an actor
because all that side of it where you
someone asks you to be in something and
there's that flattering feeling and then
you're like oh shoot now how am I gonna
make this work but I feel like I would
be more nervous about
it wasn't and I think I am nervous about
auditioning because it's not about like
just like okay we're gonna do this you
know like when the cameras there and
we're all like working on the characters
in the story that just makes so much
more sense than just trying to do the
right impress somebody yeah trying to
impress somebody or doing the confident
that you know most of addition about
confidence and I like them I'm just a
sick person sensitive soul why don't you
use your acting to be confident in your
auditions the double act what what about
that would that work cuz you're such a
good actor yeah okay I will and when
everyone's that time I have the
confident yeah pretend you're having
heart but then it takes a lot of work
cuz i prepare us so much right no like
we work so really about lazy this is
about laziness if I just prepared every
audition like her like layer for like a
year yeah why don't you do that okay
I'll do that okay and lastly are either
of you taking acting classes because
you're within the industry you're
working you had great chemistry in the
film but you still have to kind of hone
your craft or so much going on I don't
um I mean I took like some cult e-type
acting classes in Austin there was
Meisner method a long time ago and it's
weirdly has stayed with me my service is
great and I've also just yeah I think I
just like Linda's was saying because I
do write and direct so much i'm in that
world so much and we're always trying to
find truthful moments and so that kind
of like keeps you sharp i think i think
if you don't do it for a while like my
friend Jenny and I were joking should we
do this short film well it might be bad
but we have to do it or take acting
classes because they're to see you get
rusty
it's it's a problem I don't know I
probably should yeah I've done a little
bit of when you're doing I right now
yeah well you both had great chemistry
thanks i was very believable thanks it
was a it was an act was it okay no yeah
we hate each other yeah we hate each
other's guts we have no fun together
ever never it's not my second favorite
human on the planet who shot you my
girlfriend oh don't get me in trouble
next question